famously it's been much discussed but
it's so riveting you had this work
Dynamic uh with the actor Claus kinsky
and there's something in it that I
understand I understand because uh I've
I've watched all the films I've watched
the documentaries about the making of
the films I've seen him completely lose
control uh I've seen in in real
time uh people who are working on the
film plotting to kill kinsky uh kinsky
plotting to and threatening to kill you
you plotting to kinsky and I I swear to
you that what I'm saying is true right
now I've worked in comedy for you know
40 years and for 30 of those years I
worked many times out in the field
making comedy under duress in strange
conditions and I've wanted to kill
people that I've worked with one of
them's here oh uh
no but I've I but I've I've been I've
gotten to an altered state at times I've
been hungry and cold and we've needed to
get this shot and a lot of what I do is
uh somewhat improvisational and I need
to improvise something and make
something happen yeah and I've you have
to deliver I I have to deliver something
and I do think there are times when I've
gone I've I've kind of I've gone to
another state uh and I'm thinking
specifically of an episode I did where
we were shooting in Italy and it was
late in the day and we were exhausted
and suddenly we had to shoot a thing
where we're hunting for Truffles and I
just I started to I started to lose it
and I think I lost my mind during the
Truffle hunt and started hopping around
like a rabbit now anyone watching it
might
think uh I don't know what's happening
with Conan or maybe he's just doing this
because he thinks it's funny no I really
did lose lose it and have this kind of
Madness but I also understand I'm kind
of in love with it I there's there's a
part of me that is attracted to it and
of course what you were doing multiply
that by a thousand your work with kinsky
but when you say afterwards no we were
brothers you to most people that would
seem impossible that this man could be
screaming at you and abusing you and you
screaming back at him but no I
understand it I understand how you can
go through that with someone but also
cherish that bond does
that it's hard to describe it and in my
book I describe quite a bit of about it
um number one there is a side to all
this which is
hilarious uh number two I've never lost
it I cannot remember that I ever lost it
I've always been the calmest of calm in
such situations don't it he would scream
at the at the native uh people in the in
the rainforest and they would huddle sit
down because they they solved their
conflicts very quietly whispering in
Whispering
voices and they came afterwards to me
and one of their Chiefs said to me you
know
um we were afraid but don't you believe
we were afraid of this screaming
madman they were afraid of me because I
was so quiet ah okay and I I really
meant business and in in moments of real
confrontation kinsky understood when I
explained to him things very very calmly
this is impermissible this cannot be
done what you are trying there's a task
that is beyond the two of us we have to
stick to it or
else and he would know that this or else
would mean he would be a dead man within
30 seconds
flat I didn't have to spell it
out you just did though yeah that's
[Laughter]
incredible that's good you're doing it
now you're doing it now let's no let's
let's put it let's put it simply yeah um
you have to you have to have it in you
to U stop at a certain moment and and to
understand yes you do not do this you're
not going to kill each other it's a
beautiful script yes which is outside of
the movie and uh the script is not going
to happen otherwise you end up on death
row and I have made nine films on death
row and I know that every single one on
death row that I met men and women were
only a step away from what I am or what
almost all of us are yeah that's true
very human human
beings it's interesting because there's
this new movement that's been discussed
lately and it was written about the
other day I think in the New York York
Times which said if you when dealing
with someone who's out of control or
psychotic they say become a gray rock
become Bland and very very sort of
almost disinterested and they say it's
the best way to treat them so had you
screamed back at kinsky no and and and
entertained and tried to meet him scream
for scream the whole thing would have
blown up by staying yeah almost inert as
you did no we had a plane crash
and only garbled messages in our camp we
didn't know exactly where was it how
many people can we was this a plane that
was coming to this film shoot toour film
uh toour Set uh transporting extras and
um I tried to make sense what it what it
was in kinsky at that morning we served
uh coffee uh in all the huts and his he
was the last one because we altered the
the line of who would be first or last
his coffee was lukewarm he he just lost
it over it and he kept yelling and
screaming for an hour and a half foam at
his mouth I mean literally I'm not
exaggerating screaming at the top of his
lung that close to my face that close
and I try to explain close there's a
plane down we need to understand what
the radio the garbled radio is trans
mitting to us so and finally I couldn't
get rid of him I went to my Hut I had
one little piece of chocolate very good
chocolate left and I stood right in his
face and ate the chocolate that was too
much for him because chocolate was the
most valuable item in the camp yes and I
ate my last piece of chocolate and he he
just fell silent and through yeah yes
it's like you you can't you shut down
the computer it just went to the it went
to the app logo there's nothing he could
do at that
moment